[Musique]
bienvenue pour cette nouvelle édition du
7 8 politique sur tv fille le 11e il
faudra voter pour désigner nos
représentants à l'assemblée nationale
qu'elle majorité pour débuter cette
présidence d' emmanuel macron
aujourd'hui deux invités dans un instant
yasmine belmadi
elle se présente dans la 2e
circonscription des yvelines sous
l'étiquette du front national tout
d'abord je reçois jean michel fourgous
bonjour j'ai lu candidats les
républicains udi dans la 11e
circonscription des yvelines vous avez
déjà occupé ce poste de député de 93 à
97 puis de 2002 à 2012 vous est aussi
maire d'elancourt vice-présidente saint
quentin en yvelines en charge de
l'économie et conseiller départemental
pourquoi ce poste de député vous
intéressant vous avez déjà de nombreux
mamba même parce que on m'a baissé de
20% mes moyens
depuis cinq ans par tant que maire et en
tant que mère elle encourt ainsi que mes
collègues d'ailleurs
donc je pense qu'aujourd'hui si on veut
pousser nono bien sûr nos projets il
faut aller rétablir un peu quelques
règles du jeu a semblé et relancer la
croissance tout dépend de la croissance
la croisant ses skis
si l'entreprise marche bien les recettes
rentrer vous remplissez les caisses et
donc vous pouvez redistribuer vers les
collectivités vers les communes donc il
faut rétablir a déjà c'est l'urgence
voilà pour pouvoir retrouver un niveau
de vie qu'on n'aurait jamais dû perdre
et deuxièmement il ya un problème aussi
qu'on me vole beaucoup c'est le problème
de communautarisme qui a pris une
dimension hors norme et notamment ces
dernières années il va falloir prendre
des mesures qui correspondent aux
attentes de nos administrés on ne peut
pas laisser un pays qui n'a plus
d'identité qui sait plus où choisissons
ses frontières à propos de cette 11e
circonscription qui comporte je le
rappelle les communes notamment de
trappes la verrière elancourt encore le
mesnil saint denis vous êtes
représentant des républicains vous étiez
auparavant l ump est ce qu'aujourd'hui
vous faites partie 2
ces hommes politiques macro compatibles
c'était le l appellation à la mode est
ce que vous imaginez gouverner au sens
du us goûter et recomposées quand même
schéma kron c'est moins pire que
monsieur hamon en économie bon il faut
quand même le dire même si je ne partage
pas
bonjour choix entreprises et des choses
qui sont bien que je veux très tout ce
qui sera bon pour l'emploi je le voterai
pas bon il a retiré les rythmes
scolaires écouter quelqu'un de calamité
et qui a touché à la performance de
scolaire de nos enfants et s'est
immobilisée on va ramener contre des
nouveaux rythmes scolaires donc ont mis
en place éventuellement il devrait y
avoir une remise en place de l'e des
anciens rythme retour à la semaine de
quatre jours ça pourrait se faire pour
2018 voire dès 2017 par décret encore
faut-il qu'il y ait la publication du
décret vous ferez partie des premiers on
imagine vu votre opposition à cette
réforme à revenir ces quatre jours oui
oui parce que c'est moi qui ai le
premier souligné la dangerosité de cette
réforme qui va toucher bien sûr à la
performance scolaire à la concentration
de nos enfants est il assez grave donc
on voit bien que c'est un échec c'est
très stressant on ne va pas attendre
donc c'est bien et j'ai félicité
d'ailleurs voilà là l'équipe de monsieur
va prendre le dessus à partir ne
manquant c'est bien il faut le dire il
faut être au-dessus des partis vous
savez moi je suis très pragmatique
donc voilà l'économie c'est pareil
simplement là on est je trouve
extrêmement délicat discret c'est sur ce
problème dont j'entends moi dans mon
porte à porte dans mon nom mais en et
vous au talent on me parle beaucoup de
ce problème de laïcité
les gens ne supportent plus de voir la
transformation de ce pays
on veut la garder notre identité notre
culture nos valeurs faut pas que ce soit
mis en cause et le silence est très
lourd de monsieur macron là dessus ou 2
ou même de ces deux de ses candidats
qu'on lui avait des bonnes choses
moi de toute façon aujourd'hui quand
j'arrive si j'arrive là sur nationale
j'ai déjà 100 députés qui ne qui me
soutiennent ce que je veux le sud ils
m'ont nommé porte parole parce que j'ai
alimenter 20 propositions économiques
pour du groupe génération d'entreprises
et de la richesse en france voilà donc
voilà c'est bien sûr j'ai tout de suite
comme des moyens pour pour aller très
vite et je soutiendrai les mesures
économiques qui vont dans le bon sens ce
lot il ya comme une petite chose qu'il a
nous a laissés effectivement la mesure
sur la taxe d'habitation à la question
que j'allais vous poser cette
suppression de la taxe d'habitation pour
80% des ménages taxe d'habitation qui
est remplie principalement les caisses
justement des collectivités locales les
communes les agglomérations
s'il devait y avoir cette suppression
est ce qui nous inquiète c'est chez
makro et 10
là on est au delà de la gauche ou de la
droite bon c'est typiquement une mesure
pour taper sur l'électorat de droite
parce que en enlevant prier que 10% des
français qui payent l'impôt
enfin il ya 10% des français qui payent
70% en impôts soit retenu
donc là il faut bien que ça c'est encore
une mesure contre contre les lecteurs à
droite parce que vous allez vous allez
concentrer
le reste sur les propriétaires sur les
gens qui paient une taxe foncière donc
ça c'est pas bien ça c'est pas bien et
après de dire chiche au dessus de la
gauche maintenant c'est une mesure
parfaitement politicienne et je regrette
d'ailleurs que monsieur macron dans ces
investitures sur les 577 députés qu'il
investit il y en a que 50 qui sont de
droite
donc ça veut dire 90 % sont de gauche
dont d'ailleurs les deux tutélaire et
suppléments qu'il investit sur la 11e
donc ça ça nous inquiète ça nous fait
peur
si c'est des mesures ça c'est une mesure
politicienne qui suivait rendez vous
savez c'est la droite qui va payer parce
que c'est ça c'est l'électorat doit de
cap et ça c'est pas très bien on va
évoquer les propositions vous avez parlé
de laïcité notamment juste je voudrais
qu'on revoie les résultats lors de
l'élection présidentielle sur cette
circonscription certaines de certaines
des communes pardon emmanuel macron
était à arriver en tête jean luc
mélenchon a aussi réalisé un excellent
score on voit les résultats sur l
encours sur traps ou encore sur sur la
verrière dans ce scrutin vous allez
retrouver justement benoît hamon est ce
que c'est aujourd'hui votre principal
adversaire quel regard vous portez sur
son sur son bilan
le député dans sa fonction exacte de ce
que nous avons il avait promis des
emplois tout le monde en fait génération
emplois d'avenir on peu de preuves
emplois divers résultats sur la sur la
11e c'est presque 3000 chemin de plus
dont mille chômeurs de plus cette frappe
ça c'est grave on avait trois mille
chômeurs à 3 points à 4000 aujourd'hui
augmentation de 33%
c'est exactement l'inversé ce qui est
sûr c'est grave bon deuxièmement et
rythme scolaire c'est une catastrophe
en plus en plus il a un problème de
sincérité quand ils s'expriment notre
ami annoncé qu' il dit un jour oui si
j'ai des preuves ça va même ça marche et
il dit les bénéfices sont immenses pour
l'enfant de la réforme dans ce cas dit
ça érudit mais d'où vous tenez j'ai une
étude qui manquent mais surtout bédié
champions et bien entendu cette étude
des n'a pas existé il inventait et je
peux vous dire se lancer dans une telle
expérience avec les enfants dehors
d'avoir d'aidé déstabiliser des équipes
pédagogiques les enfants les parents les
profs
tout ça pour c'était simplement un effet
d'image c'est vrai que c'est triste donc
j'ai un mauvais souvenir lui dire de sa
vie le chômage séparés et troisième
essai le plus grave et c'est pour çà
dire que son suppléant bien sûr la
quitter le grec lui c'est sûr il sort du
communautarisme
il a évoqué devant villa alex et jean
philippe monnet et le communautarisme
attrape ses c'est devenu à dire c'est
même pas l'intérêt des musulmans cirque
eux on les a poussé le zèle la plus
radicale a pris la main et et poussa des
à des comportements et le
communautarisme c'est quoi en finale
c'est que on s'isole et puis on rejette
les autres qui sont pas comme vous qui
ont pas la même religion
ça c'est une erreur trois points comment
ce problème de communautarisme vous le
ressentez sur le terrain sur cette 11e
circonscription spécifiquement qui
comporte je le redis les communes de
trappes la verrière notamment sur la
commune de trappes et on suit dans
l'actualité les différents problèmes
justement de communautarisme vous le
ressentez sur le terrain soit elle
encourt aussi peut-être
ah oui dans les commentaires au delà du
ressenti des maux un changement du
paysage de toute une commune
voilà ça pose un problème inédit
réaction aussi de notre population
et puis on sent bien dire que voilà le
le l'identité française la culture
française les valeurs françaises le mode
le mode de vie des français est
contestée de plus en plus bon ça c'est
c'est pas possible
et il faudra bien sûr revoir des règles
claires on est fiers
des deux français on doit bien sûr et
mis la france
mais quelles sont les valeurs françaises
sont les règles et les lois qu'il
faudrait aujourd'hui c'est pas déjà
cherchées problème aussi de d'extrémisme
que tout individu qui a une quelconque
relation avec un courant bien sûr aux
terroristes doit être exclu de ce pays
étrange et bien sûr sans aucun état
d'âme et ce doit être le plus le plus
immédiat possible les les prêches
doivent se faire en français avec des
imams qui sont financés par la france
lee moss kylie d'elle
donc on doit redevenir française on
respecte la religion musulmane de fixer
des règles claires
rien n'est clair aujourd'hui et monsieur
a - a laissé un vraiment inclut un
désordre là dedans à trappes qui dessert
les l'immense majorité des musulmans
modérés qui du coup se retrouvent
encadrés par les plus les plus les plus
il faut bien sûr revenir là dessus et
simplifié et que chacun retrouve un
amour de la france un respect des
valeurs françaises de l'éducation
française voilà et j'ai la majorité des
musulmans modérés sont tout à fait prêts
à bien sûr admettre cela l'éducation
cela fait partie des trois axes que vous
avez aussi dégagé pour cette campagne
avec l'emploi et la sécurité sur
l'éducation vous avez oeuvré pour le
numérique au sein de votre commune
d'elancourt votre volonté c'est de
l'étendre à l'ensemble de la
circonscription si vous êtes élu député
ou un au delà sur les autres si
reconstruire mais je pense que d un
candidat 2 devrait arriver avec quelque
chose que je vois beaucoup de candidats
mais écoutez vous êtes candidat à la
députation c'est important vous allez
gérer 300 milliards là où les faire des
lois pour les pour les hommes
je dois d des gens qui se présentent
qu'ils n'ont jamais dirigé des hommes et
des femmes et qui vont faire des lois
demain sur les hommes et les femmes
ils ont jamais dirigé un budget sert qui
vont c'est une mesure sans s'en soucier
de l'impact budgétaire on a vu les
rythmes scolaires ça devrait rien coûter
souvenez-vous ça coûte plus de 5
milliards aujourd'hui aux contribuables
donc non glace ça c'est important donc
il faut quelques moins avoir réussi
quelque chose vous apporter une
expérience vous n'allez pas chercher un
statut ou une valorisation c'est vous
apporter une valeur ajoutée vous avez
vos preuves que vous est fait sur le
terrain le bon l'éducation ou d'en
parler bien sûr que l encours reste une
référence
aujourd'hui nationale puisque je crois
même que le nouveau patron d'apple
europe vient juste d'être nommé il est
dit
la première ville que je veux les voir
son éducation celle en cours bapt est
donc là mais tout le recevoir mon donc
voyez bien que voilà aujourd'hui on a en
a une infrastructure pour les enfants on
apprend avec plaisir et l'encours et on
enseigne plaisir parce que 10 des profs
donc bien sûr ce mode il doit être
générale disque el-kader le nouveau
ministre d'éducation je le connais je me
suis blanca et élimination je
travaillerai avec plaisir vécu parce
qu'ils partagent le même le même combat
sur la modernisation de l'éducation et
sur bien sûr réels et les résultats
scolaires de nos enfants juste un
dernier mot concernant votre programme
sur l'aspect sécuritaire la mise en
place de ce commissariat du futur dont
on parle depuis des années on en parlait
aussi lorsque vous étiez est déjà député
est ce que là les choses pourraient
s'accélérer c'est quelque chose que vous
pourriez porter à la ctc de ce comice
elle concernerait toute l'agglomération
et même au delà mais même les
circonscriptions
bien sûr il s'agit alors faisait
remarquer que j'ai déjà commencé à armer
ma police municipale on est la première
commune elle faire donc
donc on a une infrastructure très
moderne donc bien sûr ce commissariat du
futur permettrait de coordonner toutes
les nouvelles techniques de toutes les
technologies pour aller plus vite dans
les interventions pour bien entendu donc
c'est l'intérêt général ce commissaire a
été attribuée d'ailleurs à elancourt
dont pour pour la coordination le lieu
pour le lieu nation c'est un outil qui
va augmenter je pense considère la situe
à des jeux rappelle qu'ils ont cours
reste on a baissé de -2 30% l'insécurité
enfin les faits constatés là donc on est
en effectivement bien positionné en plus
son travail avec beaucoup de
laboratoires de recherche on est dans
une zone innovation je vous le rappelle
on est dans la zone dans les huit zones
mondial de l'innovation donc il s'agit
que sur la sécurité on soit un exemple
aussi roulé sur l'éducation il faut
construire demain soir sécurité une
toute dernière question concernant cette
campagne de la législative dans la 11e
circonscription vous trouvez cette
campagne particulièrement difficile
délicate
quels sont les mots vous pourriez
utiliser parce que sans faire référence
à l'actualité
on a pu lire un article à papier du
canard enchaîné auquel vous avez répondu
notamment via un communiqué que vous
avez aussi distribué sur les différentes
communes de la circonscription
oui je vois que l'on osé l'accuser
d'avoir été difficile en tout cas lors
d'un contrôle routier c'est ce qui avait
été reproché il avait été dit pour
uncharted et s'est dit bien sûr dès
qu'elle nie mais je trouve que cette
campagne aussi bien présidentielles que
législatives et très violente
oui on
j'ai été comme beaucoup de contrôles là
on m'a fait souvent le ballon là et puis
je après dans l éthylomètre une machine
très précis je me les héros g il invité
comme beaucoup de gens va lui succéder
contre le cip la voilà cette affaire et
on a essayé de faire sortir un canard de
faire un plat enfin sous l'impulsion des
adversaires de ces traînées donc bon ben
ça fait un flop
d'ailleurs et c'est terminé mais ça
montre bien là là là voilà la sas on
doit avoir des gens de sincérité des
gens d'expérience nous ont fait leurs
preuves sur conques on regarde les
résultats des gens leur expérience
aujourd'hui y voyez c'est celui qui qui
qui manquent plus qui trichent le plus
qui est élu attention attention on peut
pas continuer comme ça il y avait main
les plaisirs comme la farine cette
campagne spécifiquement est plus
difficile que les autres jeux wii je
trouve je trouve que les violentes on
l'a vu aux présidentielles idem mais y'a
pas qu'ici je la trouve beaucoup plus
violente que d'habitude là c'est le jeu
c'est d'enlever toute image enfin c'est
la ville méthodes trotskistes marxistes
a dans le bide toute image morale à son
adversaire et on dit n'importe quoi sur
lui bonjour pas certain que c est tout
ça il ya eu beaucoup d'impact mais faut
à chaque fois répondre que ça s'est très
c'est très long et qui on parle pas des
vrais problèmes dont on parle pas du
chômage en parle pas demain il faut
remplir les caisses
si vous ne savez pas rentrer les caisses
vous avez rien à faire demain à allait
être député si vous n'avez jamais rempli
les caisses
sur le plan financier c'est pas le
moment où il faisait dire et vous
présenter quand il faudra redistribuées
pour l'instant voilà il faut redonner
confiance à tout le réseau qui permet de
produire la richesse pour produire des
emplois marchands c'est ça l'urgence
et puis le modèle éducatif obama
délicate il qu'ils soient qu'ils
redeviennent un exemple le mode élite et
du français ne lit plus et on affiche de
bas de vos propositions justement au
cours de cette émission il vous aurez
bientôt l'occasion d'échanger avec les
autres candidats lors du débat que nous
organisons prochainement sur cette
antenne merci à jean michel fourgous
candidats les républicains unis dans
cette 11e circonscription le 7-8
politique se poursuit et nous partons
dans la troisième circonscription à
présent avec un autre candidat des
républicains philippe brillault il
entend au succès d henri guaino écarté
de ce scrutin par sa famille politique
présentation signé nicolas kirillovitch
comment va réagir ça va bien
voilà cette fois ci pourrait être la
bonne mère du chéné depuis 28 ans
conseiller départemental et candidats
les républicains sur la troisième
circonscription des yvelines philippe
brillault espère enfin être élu député
lui qui tente sa chance pour la sixième
fois d'affilée et qui souhaite incarner
le rôle d'un élu constructif face à
emmanuel macron de preuve la république
a un seul objectif c'est de permettre à
la france de revivre toutes les qualités
qu'il peut avoir avec des réformes
par contre les projets de ses objectifs
on ne les voit pas encore c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous souhaitons
avoir un contre-pouvoir positif auprès
du prénom de la république ne sera pas
en contradiction mais qui sera en
correction connu pour son engagement
dans la manif pour tous l'ancien médecin
philippe brillault souhaite mettre en
avant son ancrage local pour faire la
différence en 2012
il n'avait récolté que 6 34% des
suffrages et voyez alors le candidat
henri guaino remporté la députation
cinq ans plus tard avec l'étiquette et
l'air sur le dos il souhaite s'engager
notamment sur une réforme importante de
la santé il faut qu'on re motiver les
jeunes à faire médecine
on a besoin de médecin il faut savoir
redéfinir aussi le financement de la
santé est ce qu'on le fait peser sur le
travail est ce qu'on faisait avec à csg
tout ça ce sont les vrais débats des
semaines qui viennent car aujourd'hui on
a des hôpitaux qui sont dans des grandes
difficultés on a des libéraux
s'interroge pour continuer
autre axe de campagne mise en avant avec
sa suppléante sylvie ce vin montel la
fiscalité le logement ou encore la
sécurité pour cette élection philippe
brillault fera face à plusieurs novice
en politique quand je vois monsieur
collomb j'ai pas l'impression que c'est
du jeune quand je vois monsieur berrou
j'ai pas l'impression de barbus jeunes
et jeux pour décliner d'autres je pense
qu'un bon équilibre c'est du junior et
du senior au total 14 candidats seront
opposés sur la troisième circonscription
des yvelines avec notamment l'inconnue
de la république en marche béatrice
piron à gauche le parti socialiste
europe écologie les verts et le parti
communiste ont réussi à s'entendre pour
soutenir la candidature de nicolas eu en
plateau à présent et yasmine benzema
bonjour vous êtes candidate du front
national dans la 2e circonscription d
line on va vous présenter en quelques
mots vous êtes conseiller régional
également et puis au civil cadres dans
la finance pourquoi cette candidature
dans la 2e circonscription des yvelines
bien si la ville enfin c'est la
circonscription où j'habite et où je
travaille également
je suis responsable de la
circonscription depuis trois ans pour le
front national
donc j'anime la vie politique pour les
militants et sympathisants du front
national et je me suis impliqué à partir
des municipales sur la liste municipale
de vélizy front national en 2014 puis
j'ai été candidate au départemental en
2015 aux régionales où j'ai été élu et
maintenant pour la députation donc dans
cette deuxième des circonscriptions
globalement dans le département des
yvelines des résultats pour le front
national n'ont pas été excellent n'ont
pas été très bons n'ont pas été à la
hauteur de ceux du du national sur la 2e
circonscription dans une ville comme
vélizy 14% au premier tour 24 % au
second voisins le bretonneux on va le
voir aussi un peu plus de 16% 16,43 %
pour le deuxième tour ça va être
difficile dans cette circonscription
spécifiquement mais on tente notre
chance comme partout où je pense qu'il
ya des choses à régler notamment les
évènements des derniers événements à
vélizy renforce un peu ce que ce que
l'on dit depuis des années sur la
sécurité sur la présence de la police de
proximité sur justement les problèmes
qui entraîne le laxisme judiciaire est
bon par ailleurs je suis aussi une 110
d'être très attaché à la famille et je
suis quand même présente sur le terrain
depuis pas mal de temps donc on verra
le front national se porte plutôt bien
au delà de cette 2e circonscription va
revenir sur vos propositions mais ce
qu'il y aura une remise en cause quoi
qu'il arrive après ce que ce scrutin
législatif mais je pense que là on a vu
avec les présidentielles que on était
arrivé à un moment où on peut s'allier
avec d'autres partis attirer d'autres
personnes est donc fort cela
effectivement il faut remettre un peu
grand ordre mais plus d'ouverture on l'a
déjà fait des films et je pense qu'il
faut travailler vraiment à la structure
aussi qui à la base était imparti ou
vraiment on n'avait pas beaucoup
d'alliés on avait du mal à avoir des
alliés et maintenant on arrive à avoir
des alliés je pense qu'il faut justement
montré les signes pour s'ouvrir et puis
adapter la structure justement à
l'ouverture vous parler de ses alliés
debout la france nicolas dupont aignan
néanmoins debout la france présente des
candidats dans les différentes
circonscriptions vous avez un candidat
debout la france et à sa route par
exemple dans cette 2e circonscription
des yvelines
donc des alliances mais pas pour
l'instant mais il ya eu des alliances
pour les présidentielles parce que je
pense qu'on avait un projet quand même
assez assez semblables et face à la
candidature de manuel macron c'est vrai
qu' on était les seuls à défendre une
vision un peu plus identitaire un peu
plus centré sur la protection de la
famille sûr
sur la défense de la france vis-à-vis de
l'union européenne telle qu'elle est et
non pas de l'europe mais deux millions
européenne est bon pour les législatives
c'est le jeu démocratique et puis le mot
le mode de financement des partis
politiques qui est votre entre aussi en
jeu et qui fait qu'on est différents
candidats à se présenter avec des
programmes toutefois assez similaire
puisque effectivement chaque voix va
porter sur un candidat permet de
rapporter quelques euros pour les
formations politiques et c'est pour ça
qu'il ya de nombreux candidats sur les
différentes circonscriptions de
nombreuses différentes formations qui
représentent différentes couleurs justes
pour conclure sur cette question de
l'évolution du front national probable
après cette élection législative le
départ possible de florian philippot par
exemple parce que ce serait une bonne ou
une mauvaise chose pour vous ces
seigneurs fondé une association les
patriotes par exemple on sent qu'il
prépare peut-être un peu l'avenir aussi
pour l'instant c'est plus une manière
d'envoyer des signaux pour présenter
l'autre et que le front national enfin
c'est vraiment les patriotes mais ça
n'empêche que pour l'instant notre
programme reste le même et on verra lors
du congrès qui s'organisera d'ici la fin
de l'année ce qu'il en sera mais sur vos
différentes propositions à présent vous
avez parlé de sécurité notamment à
vélizy vous avez mentionné mais
rapidement vous étiez plutôt porté sur
la question de la famille alors quelles
sont les propositions vous portez sur la
famille aujourd'hui dans les actes alors
sur la famille déjà nous sommes pour
l'abrogation de la loi taubira
effectivement parce que je pense que le
mariage c'est l'union entre un homme et
une femme
il n'empêche qu'on propose un pack
s'améliorer pour tout ce qui est
question de fiscalité et de succession
tout ce qu'il ya tout le côté
administratif et qui n'empêche qu'on
respecte les couples homosexuels mais je
pensais
j'ai aussi dans mon entourage des
personnes qui équipes partagent ce point
de vue que le mariage c'est vraiment le
nom d'un homme ou d'une femme mais il
n'y a pas de sas et c'est surtout tout
ce qui est entraîné derrière par par
cette position et cette loi qui est la
pma et puis surtout la gpa qui
s'apparente pour moi de l'esclavagisme
l'esclavagisme du corps de la femme et
puis qui pose pas beaucoup de questions
éthiques à la fois pour la mère qui
porte l'enfant et qui sont des tâches et
l'enfant qui du coup n'est de cette
manière et est adoptée la
marchandisation justement à la fois du
corps de la femme et de l'enfant sur
cette question de la famille vous partez
cette proposition-là sur les questions
de sécurité
peut-être procès oui alors je suis pour
le rétablissement de l'autorité des
forces de l'ordre et de leur respect
c'est vrai qu'on voit régulièrement le
fait que d'une part par le fait de leur
absence le fait qu'ils n'ont pas d'ordre
pour intervenir souvent elles sont un
peu démunis et et sont souvent plus
soupçonné presque que les délinquants en
face d'eux est donc
les conséquences de la saison j'ai dit
c'est rossi qui fait que ces forces de
l'ordre en fait ne sont pas respectées
ni crainte et du coup on voit des
délinquants multirécidivistes qui
continue et qui qui persistent dans leur
dans leurs actes délictueux et dans leur
incivilité aussi des fois et par
ailleurs nous sommes pour le
rétablissement d'une d'une police de
proximité qui passe que par hasard qu'on
le voit sur vélizy le commissariat est
fermé depuis que le commissariat fermé
je suis en retard civilité voir
d'incident ne cesse d'augmenter et on a
atteint un summum la semaine dernière
avec les émeutes qui ont suivi le
tournage d'un clip sauvage sur le toit
de mon bâtiment justement sur premières
loges quel regard vous portez sur les
premiers jours du gouvernement macron
pour l'instant il ya beaucoup d'effets
d'annoncé pas grand chose de concret si
ce n'est les soupçons qui portent sur
différents ministres actuels et que
bizarrement la justice dit qu'il n'a
rien qu'il n'y arrive pas dans lequel je
dit sûr qu'il ya des enquêtes ouvertes
sur voilà sur les affaires concernant
notamment richard ferrand est ce que
vous appelez la démission par exemple je
trouve que moi il devrait s'expliquer un
peu plus il devrait y avoir une enquête
et pourquoi pas puisqu'ils ont dit qu'il
devait être exemplaire démissionné parce
que même s'ils prônent que c'est légal
je trouve que jaka pour monsieur ferrand
par exemple la taille l enrichissement
personnel et il ya pour le moins un
conflit d'intérêts visible quoi donc moi
je pense qu'on peut pas gouverner dirigé
demandé aux français d'être exemplaire
proposait même une loi pour une
moralisation de la vie politique
et puis à côté de ça 128 dans les poches
pardonnez moi l'expression mais si à
fait ça une dernière question cette
élection et et national puisqu'il s'agit
d'envoyer des députés à l'assemblée pour
décider ensuite des lois mais c'est
aussi une élection qui se joue en local
et donc dans une circonscription et une
circonscription qui est assez peu
homogène de vélizy à magny les hameaux
en passant par voisins-le-bretonneux
comment vous allez brasser ses
différents types de population et ces
différentes problématiques parce
qu'elles sont très différentes entre
vélizy manille ou encore voisins oui
même on pourrait parler de la vallée de
chevreuse mais je pense que sur notre
vision nationale du sujet et même ça
s'adapte totalement au local on est pour
favoriser les circuits courts donc pour
favoriser une agriculture durable
respectueuse de l'environnement par
exemple dans la partie rurale de de la
circonscription ça favoriserait le
développement bad comme les fermes qu'on
a la ferme de viltain la forme et au
sida est par ailleurs le développement
économique par le développement des
petits artisans et commerçants dont
crevettes revitaliser les centre villes
et et du coup ça permettrait d'avoir une
vie et par exemple dans les petites
communes rurales de permettre de ne pas
aller à ladoux ne pas aller juste au
sein de commercial pour pouvoir faire
ses courses voilà et donc ça concerne
aussi les grosses villes pour que ça
évite de devenir des villes dortoirs
la sécurité c'est quand même la sphère
de tous c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas tout à
fait les mêmes problématiques à vélizy
cas concernés 1110 mais ils sont aussi
soumis à des délinquants c'est celle
d'avoir une police ou enfin des forces
de l'ordre à proximité et en reste et
même parce que on voit aussi que
certaines fois les pompiers sont mis
aussi dans le même panier alors qu'eux
ils sont là pour sauver des vies c'est
c'est regrettable je pense que ce sera
bénéfique à tout le monde
merci je rappelle que vous êtes
candidate sur la 2e circonscription des
yvelines pour le front national on va
revoir juste l intégralité des
formations qui se présente avec la
classification officielle du ministère
de l'intérieur
nous refermons ce 7,8 politique
prochaine édition le 7 juin d'ici là la
campagne est à suivre dans nos éditions
quotidiennes du journal et puis chaque
semaine dans cette dans cette émission
et puis vous le savez vont commencer et
dès le 31 mai au soir les débats dans
les différentes circonscriptions avec
tous les candidats présents en plateau
merci encore à vous c'est la fin de
cette 8e politique
[Musique]